service s kids und herzlich willkommen
zur dritten kind vorstellung aus der
ender game serie und zwar werde ich euch
heute das kit assassine zeigen
so oder so wieder und wie immer bevor
wir loslegen kurz ein blick in die
beschreibung die auto wie folgt der
assassine startet mit einem holzschwert
sowie einem weißen leder helm und macht
von hinten mehr schaden
das kit wir direkt mal aus oder
zusammengefasst heißt das bis in eine
klasse die war wie fast alle neuen
klassen oder ich glaube alle keine
besonderen fähigkeiten im pvp hat das
heißt ja wobei eigentlich schon aber
nicht im sinne von nicht im sinne von
bomber oder känguru dem springen können
oder dinge explodieren lassen
wir machen einfach von hinten mehr
schaden das ist ja es ist wirklich
praktisch aber von hinten echt schon gut
verteilen kann
allerdings muss man auch wirklich von
hinten kommen und das ist ja nicht immer
so leicht wenn man sagt wenn leute den
trecker haben dafür sich von den allzu
schlecht weil die enger sehen aber ich
würde sagen wir schauen einfach mal
jetzt gleich in die runde rein sehen uns
gleich wieder und dann geht nach sodass
würde der runde es geht gleich los
und bevor ich ja dann auch staaten noch
eine kurze anmerkung ich habe mit dem
kind bisher noch keine runde gewonnen
deswegen ist es wahrscheinlich dass ich
diese runde hier auch human werdet
verließ ihn nicht gewinnen ihr wisst
wird einfach in echt zeigen wie dieses
kit so abgeht
das war nicht ganz fitte anfangs gut es
ist nämlich ähnlich wie bei den anderen
kids die nicht besonders schnell laufen
so dass man eigentlich ziemlich verpackt
hat wenn man am anfang keine guten
sachen bekommt weil dann die kängurus
ausschwärmen und sich den ganzen stadt
holen denn hier sich einheimsen oder
whatever die klauen sich dann einfach
weil er einfach schnell seite springen
was keine chance kannst du nicht machen
wenn jetzt gerade keine ändert ein hass
und gut wirst dann was das eigentlich
für dich so ihr seht ihr hier seht ihr
da oben wir haben einen weißen leder
haben diese indien kit ein halber
rüstungs punkt richtig fett auf jeden
fall besser als nichts ist es schon mal
wenn auch nicht viel besser als nichts
aber ich bin noch nicht was nicht ganz
sicher ob das jetzt frei kann oder nicht
dieses weiße teil
das kann ja meine kommentare schwer wird
es gut oder scheiße findet wie das
aussieht schreibt mir das mal unten rein
ob es was es wolle ja das regt mich auf
wenn ja wie
er schaut mein video das jetzt klasse
video session
er schaut mein video und schreibe mir im
video wirklich ein video aufnehmen
kassel kassel action so auf jeden fall
haben unser zeug hier
wer ist das wer stabil ist oder wie ein
schönes eisen schwert guck mal das jetzt
möglich viele leute von hinten erwischen
hoffentlich nicht
ein känguru töten wir immer gerne sehr
gut weil die kängurus sich die
gefährlich sind muss ich fast sagen fast
noch gefährlicher als die bombe aber
verdienen einfach ja aber man kann
eigentlich nicht weglaufen
das ist bisschen problematisch ist aber
ziemlich weit bis zum nächsten gegner
112 blöcke
egal wie gehen wir auf ihn drauf wir
hoffen mal dass er am anfang jetzt nicht
zugeklebt ist sie jetzt schon ihren chat
oder so würde uns jetzt wirklich in
schwierigkeiten bringen und wir hoffen
vor allem dass wir uns von hinten
anschleichen können
das sieht ganz gut aus aber er hat uns
wahrscheinlich schon gesehen
wir hatten ziemlich sicher schon gesehen
so ein starkes wieder weg läuft wir
wissen jetzt nicht so ausgerüstet aber
nun gold wert momentan hat schon sagen
endlich bombay street ihre zuläuft
entgehen münchen trainer wo wir wohnen
direkt gepostet
umso besser müssen jetzt aber auf jeden
fall hier nochmal nach der einen oder
anderen ändert ist auszuhalten damit ein
halber rüstungs punkt können wir dies
ohnehin garantiert nicht gewinnen
braucht man ein bisschen mehr musste
nicht lässt oben sowie sehe ich auch nix
gut gut dass wir schön gollum style
unsere unseren rohen fisch da haben bis
der gollum westermann aus herr der ringe
hat auch immer sich schön an einfluss
schon rein gesteckt die dinge richtig
widerwärtig mache jetzt auch mal auf
bevor er ist rohen fisch das ja
widerwärtig okay okay dass da mal ich
nicht sagen weil ich bin absoluter super
fan von ein känguru ja genau diese
menschen ja erst mal schön gegenseitig
und ich war mir schon die biege ganz
ehrlich weil zwei kängurus hat gebe ich
mir nicht allerdings kann man vielleicht
abstauben
ja weil das jetzt auch nicht so dass der
service schauen
ja das spricht natürlich weg eine ende
keine chance
jetzt ist wahrscheinlich ziemlich sauer
auf uns kompliziert hinterher aber gut
auch sommer machen wenn man jetzt hier
kein känguru ist sondern assassine noch
nicht so viel gesagt haben komm nein
bleibt doch auch keine chance keine
chance da hinterher zu kommen
keine chance kannst du nichts machen
schade dass das ist natürlich ein
bisschen ärgerlich gegen kängurus zu
kämpfen
geht dann einfach gar nichts weil die
einfach so krass op sind noch immer weit
kommen aber gut
der nächste gegner 110 blöcke entfernt
ich finde einfach keine ändert jetzt
also sagen scheint sich vielleicht zu
viel man muss oder so aber bis auf die
hega leben echt lange keine gesehen
ok dafür alte wärme juli 9 aber einiges
hier
holla die waldfee das erste mal hier
diesen kräften noch ein
nicht optimal hin aber juli hatten schon
helfen aber vorgeht
also wo ist der nächste wo wir können
nicht auf diesen schritt machen könnten
sogar noch tolle sachen machen ich
glaube spannend machen so vorher wolle
man die erschwert so alles klar und food
brauchen wir auch mal wieder gut da ist
ja in stein ohne kuh perfekt wenn sie
doch fahrzeuge dann ziemlich schnell
denn wenn die nächste stück stück gehen
fast einig waren sich da ein steak was
für eine geistige scheiß kleines steak
machen
es ist ein bomber geiler scheiß jetzt
gegen bomba ach du scheiße das wird
schwierig das wird schwierig leute
nächstes ein känguru oder herz wieder
springt
gescher was willst du was willst du hier
mal gucken was jetzt macht wir sind
schon die letzten beiden alter krass ok
krasse nummer dass ich nicht dass es so
schnell geht das fair mehr holz das
holzregal tag da ist eine kraft im
mainstream breaking ja gut da kann man
nicht viel gegen ihn ausrichten oder so
okay wir probieren sie es einfach mal
würde ich mal sagen
es ist ein känguru oder hätten auf jeden
fall
ok ich hab keinen bogen aber okay er gut
da fährst du kind widmen
wir kommen wie gut wir kommen gut
safak scheiße ein herz na gut das lief
eigentlich ganz gut will ich sein diese
runde
wie gesagt noch mal so zusammenfasst
dieses assassinen kit hat die effekte
man hat man statt mit einem holzschwert
das ganz praktisch macht einen leader
helm ja beides zusammen das braucht man
nicht ganz egal
dort kann man sich immer aus holz mache
eigentlich und so leder macht jetzt auch
nicht wobei schutz gegen headshots das
ist schon mal gut das ist schonmal
pluspunkt plus mann von hinten mehr
schaden aber das problem ist man
erwischt die leute wirklich selten von
hinten also so ging es mir und deswegen
würde ich sagen würde ich jetzt auf
einer skala von 1 bis 10 bewerten müsste
würde ich dem assassinen kit vielleicht
so würde glaube ich fünf von zehn
punkten geben weil es einfach ist es
nicht so wirklich praktisch das ist ganz
lustig man erwischt hat die leute selten
von hinten
gerade wenn das ende zugeht und man
kängurus bomba was weiß ich alles gegen
sich hat die erwischt man einfach nicht
von hinten weil die alle wissen über den
track benutzt wenn du noch zwei leute da
sind eigentlich keine chance
und ja für den anfang ist es ganz lustig
der maschine von hinten bisschen kaputt
schnecken für fortgeschritten spiel eher
ungeeignet deswegen gebe ich 15 punkten
und wird sagen wirklich gefallen hat
dann gibt eine positive bewertung
schreibt er in die kommentare welche
kids ihr euch nicht welche kids ihr euch
als nächstes wünscht und würde ich sagen
sehen wir uns im nächsten video wieder
haut rein und macht's gut